welcome everybody to the h3 podcasts
alive today's episode is sponsored by me
on DS hems and twitch sub subscribers
just like you you can subscribe for free
by connecting your Prime and twitch
account thanks we both have me undies on
right now let's see I need proof they
get diggin if you need goals if you
don't if you need more than Horseman
than that I don't know they're the
greatest minor please hold on money you
got on right now or you mean the pair
that you go join me that I would be
loved to be wearing right now are in the
wash nope based on what the pattern like
you have a certain pattern that you like
I like the doughnut and milk one or that
not donut milk its cereal milk they're
always releasing new designs
what's gonna find it so what I use in
order to end up all right guys what
makes it underpants dirty does create a
pattern smell they might work back from
that there's many criteria um anyway
next week's guest is the prolific shane
dawson please post your questions for
him on the subreddit those are very
helpful I just want to say I love you
guys when you go there and share your
opinions it's really helpful so thank
you everyone who participated
about two days guess obviously you've
guessed because there's been banter
already I am very hyped and pleased to
introduce these the great and amazing
rhett and Link who I have to say are a
huge inspiration of why I think we
became youtubers to begin with was
watching you guys stuff I tell a salute
Lee I understand that I wasn't supposed
to talk earlier about the underwear so
now I don't know if I can talk now good
when you throw out a big compliment the
gate is open
you're supposed to smile gently okay I
just might I'm sorry I didn't you
thought was gonna compliment you guys
more right because if the compliments
are still kind yeah you're not done
okay keep going sorry gonna say the
multi-talented song-and-dance bent the
triple-threat you must do well there's
two of us we each have one and a half
well when we had our third member of our
trio who was unfortunately wait that's
mauled triple means a three-man act I
thought it meant like this song maybe by
extending it you it would land yeah I
was trying to save you
well anyway good evening god bless
Tripathi
we don't really dance well well you know
what I guess we do you guys put your
mind yeah you would be straight-up
dancing in the rain I could see you with
an umbrella tap-dancing your way I'm
telling you the triple threat challenge
accepted
yeah it's 7:00 p.m. this is not our
usual time oh I can imagine it's been a
long day for you guys your schedule must
be insane how was your day Thursday is
our work late night so thanks for
accommodating us of course to make this
happen
yeah absolutely and we typically record
our own podcast in the in the in the
late night but instead we're on this one
so more people are gonna listen buns are
very similar so we feel very at home
yeah yeah so thank you for making it's
been a long day though so tell me about
your day what do you guys do today uh
well right now Monday through Thursday
we're shooting GMM so because there's
four videos coming out a day now I
thought it was three it's three good
mythical morning and then there's one
good mythical more that extra yeah so
there's two episodes on Monday one
episode on Tuesday want opposite on
Wednesday and then it Thursdays a
two-episode day but we also do like
we're doing things that just isn't just
us at the desk now so we shot a music
video today on a couple of segments
there's no dancing it's actually almost
like an anti dance
music video where all the dancing is
creating an impost I'm actually not
joking I started to dance at one point
and you're not they told me that I had
to be still beam to a you were right
about the dances we're going to make you
active in post right yeah we were all
the way over here we were just talking
about the first thing we shot this
morning which was with this girl who's a
contortionist and a youtuber as well
Sophie da si is her name
she'll be on upcoming yeah she'll be on
an upcoming episode of good mythical
morning but it's what right now we're in
those days where I'm like that was today
right you know what I mean
oh yeah I don't know if that's a good
thing it's intense it's an intense a lot
of different things there's just a lot
of different we've kind of got into this
habit of just kind of showing up at the
next thing and executing it and then
moving on to the next thing that may be
very different than the thing that was
right before it so you guys are at the
point kind of where you just show up how
involved because now this show has
become something new right so yeah
that's formed recently I mean it's at a
certain point we had to get somebody
else to be in charge of our schedule so
we just said what the parameters were
okay right for the sake of our families
we only want to work this amount of time
and so our only late-night is a Thursday
night and you know then you guys get
jerked around in order to try to you
know accommodate that stirred around but
that's how it for the triple threats no
yeah but it's at any point on any given
day we're worth we're thinking of or
responding to new ideas and just saying
okay yes to this idea no to this idea
shaping this idea and then prepping
other episodes they all said yes to it
that would it would be easier if we were
just showing up but yeah we're still
very much involved in the creative
process and we have a great team of
writers and we're not coming up with
they're coming up with a majority of the
initial ideas but like right before we
came here like the last thing we did
after we shot the music videos we had
like an hour-long meeting with our team
that does all our field shoots so stuff
outside so like
the wind Baker stuff that ready with you
there's that's a different team that
handles that so a different director and
then there's riders assigned to that so
we have a meeting where they kind of
pitch us what they're thinking and then
we change it or update it or give the
thumbs up I mean it used to be and then
where we're stepping into the thing that
we're shooting so when we step into the
thing we're shooting we're accessing
when we prepped it the day or a few days
before and then maybe a few weeks a week
or two before when we said yes we want
to do it so it's a little all removed
from the concepts actually being in yeah
you got to react cess it and say okay
this is this is why I was excited about
this interesting and this is what's
missing that I was excited about that I
have to interject the last second or not
whatever the case may be and it because
yeah it's it's funny we the the
conversation continued between the two
of us earlier and it was like yeah we we
used to work on something we developed
something we'd really believed in it a
video and then we'd work on it all the
way through and then we'd start the next
the next one's like chronological yeah
very linear yeah and I mean because good
mythical morning is so it's so formatted
and it you know it allowed us to hire
people who couldn't make us make it into
a system that then we kids you know not
do everything you step in the desert
yeah but it gets a little crazy
sure next week we're not shooting
anything so we do have every five weeks
we have a dark week so that's six thank
word for you guys man what we're gonna
do though is we're gonna go the two of
us are gonna leave town we're gonna go
someplace and we're gonna come up with
something else to create so really
because we well yeah it's not a vacation
we're still you just escape in yeah well
getting out of the grind of GMM so I
mean cuz we've always had something else
going on at the same time as a good
mythical morning but when it kind of
exponentially increased in November
we had to get a lot smarter about our
time to do those other things so you
guys are involved in like a high level
high high level stuff the concepts
yeah development you think that that I
think that's probably necessary for you
guys to have the time to do other stuff
like what you're describing I mean we
only did so the first two years of GMM
was you know between yes probably ninety
percent us and then starting like the
fourth season or so is when we brought
in Stevie our producer right and she had
some we were just going off of instinct
all along we had no production
experience at all she came in with some
production experience was like
if you guys want to do anything else or
you you want to we need to make this
into more of a system with efficiencies
and we need to hire the right people
interested in and at that point we
started like that was when we made the
transition so this probably 2014 was
probably the first time we started
actually having episodes would go alive
and we hadn't even watched them said
like four years ago or whatever that was
a big transition for us was like oh now
we're putting stuff up that we don't
even watch we were there when we made it
we were there putting in just because
it's you're producing too much or what
yeah because we were doing other things
it was like okay what things are we
gonna let go of so like the process is
you let go of the editing first right so
that's like even for us that was
difficult so that was like 2012 probably
letting go of the editing how did you do
that by the way how did you eventually
come out I like overcome that hurdle cuz
it's so personal
well I mean we were Jason was a guy and
we were over his shoulder like literally
I mean it is if you look at the card
table where we shot the first
incarnation of good mythical morning
right behind the card table were our two
desks push them together like just and
just to the right right out of frame was
his desk like when we were shooting the
show if if I went like this I could have
I could have easily picked it
occasionally it did happen occasionally
just keeping - yeah come on just get a
little prize right dig deep for a little
prize that's my point
well I was I was over his shoulder yeah
I mean it's it's easier again when it I
mean when it's a format like that you
can start to develop and you can you can
nitpick everything and inside and so
next time do that but it wasn't until we
found somebody who in Stevie that it was
like oh this final product that she just
oversaw is almost exactly what we would
have that's great maybe a little
different but it was just as good it was
so it was like good enough yeah cuz I
totally just as good maybe a little
different but in this in some specialist
there yeah but it was there because if
that wasn't the case then we would have
never let go and I know there's a lot of
youtubers that never let go it's hard I
feel like do you guys feel like you were
lucky to find some of that great
extremely I was kind of the catalyst
right for for doing Rancher extremely
lucky because we interviewed a couple
people and she seemed to be like she was
the smartest person that we interviewed
you know that was the thing that we were
like this person's got to be smart we're
not gonna have a lot of patience with
somebody who's not and she just very
quickly demonstrated that she was more
than just a producer she was a creative
partner so um yeah I think that's the
key because people are so and it's very
difficult to find find those people that
you can trust sure but if you can then
you can I mean we would have never done
you know the book or the tour buddy
system or any of that stuff without
being able to step out of you know a
daily show that just takes people are
like oh it's just come it's just 15
minutes a day what do you do the rest of
your time yeah you guys know that it's
it's more than you know me and Neela
tried for a month about a year or two
years ago to make a video every day we
did it for 30 days and we almost got a
divorce
hate it but every daily vlogs do and he
was only eyes like no no help was it
were they blocked no no basically good
mythical morning ripoff it is
inspiration right but obviously without
the production value and without looking
good and being good now listen it was
like a hybrid of like PewDiePie good
mythical morning we were sitting at a
desk right it was an interesting
experiment you know I just wanted to see
what it was like and it was miserable
where he was well you probably I mean
we've met you we've done a lot of stuff
that hasn't worked but you it always
works to teach you a lesson you learned
something from it and at that you almost
always leads to something else it was a
huge formative really important actually
I do really like some of those videos
that we made so it's interesting I don't
know we suffered but we we don't you
don't have to be a lot of people are
paralyzed because they're like I don't
know if this is gonna work though you
gotta quit asking that question because
it probably won't most of us huh yeah
yeah you know do you guys have you guys
have like a golden age you guys been
making content for so long I feel like
we have a golden age like when we look
back at the videos we made when we were
living in Israel uh-huh by the time we
discovered you guys we were just coming
up I just saw your like deprivation tank
video and I was like this is awesome
that's the first video I saw of yours
guys and I don't know I don't know what
there was just like a Wild West vibe
like I can never make those videos now
because they were awful quality there
was [ __ ] he produced they were just
awful but looking back with a certain
charm I guess yeah you guys feel like
you have a golden age of some sort III I
have in my mind well when we were making
our local commercials right mm-hm and we
made the first couple I mean there was
like oh nine maybe yes we made like red
house furniture which like went reeve
iral a couple of weeks ago yeah let's
stretch this so funny so weird 16 years
old YouTube does this thing where
they'll just put like your first video
on everyone's home
Paige all the sudden really I mean not
your first but like they'll go way back
in your catalog right and back here's
this really embarrassing video that you
probably should have unlisted in our
case not your kids algorithm thinks
they're ready for it yeah Jodi
they've earned the right to go deep but
anyway as you were saying we were making
I remember we were making went to
Coleman Alabama and made what we ended
up titling on YouTube epic and honest
used trailer commercial but it was this
guy who had a business Coleman
liquidation he would repo trailers and
single-wide trailers and then he would
he would sell him off his lie so used
mobile homes right this is as bad as it
gets and his name was Robert Lee and we
would we would usually we would have
like a phone interview with the people
to see if they were commercial material
but once we found out his name was
Robert Lee and we talked to his
secretary he we can never get him on the
phone we could never get we could never
get to talk to him in any way but we
said we gotta go to this guy make a
commercial and I remember we were there
making the commercial and he didn't show
up for three hours and we were
documenting it behind the scenes we had
this idea that you know we're gonna
we're just gonna document to making this
commercial so people will believe how
real it is and how little we're actually
doing but we would show we're not
changing his name or anything like that
but it was just the two of us the two of
us would get on a plane with a camera
the camera and so we documented all the
interactions and then with the same
camera the next day after we gathered
all the Intel we shot the commercial so
I think we would set up a second camera
shooting us shooting the commercial yeah
we justify just to make more of a story
on our second Channel right it became
the good mythical morning chance yeah I
know yes okay so Robert Lee finally
shows up after literally waiting for him
for hours like with the camera in my lap
I wanted to capture the moment he walked
in and he you know he walks in and I'm
like scream let's start start filming
he's like
y'all the boys from the commercial and
he just like then for the next hour he
didn't shut up telling stories I'm like
ah this is great
next day we had him like with a chainsaw
cutting down cutting limbs off of trees
in order to get a mobile home out of
this person's yard and sell it the next
day and it was it was just it was crappy
man it was fun you had this guy Minoo
it's just us us trying to make this
thing happen
it's crazy idea just kind of you know
looking at each other while this guy's
got a chainsaw chopped off by this this
guy and then we went back to the hotel
that night and we got on the phone with
Joe Penna mysteryGuitarMan mm-hmm and so
we were we were pitching him on working
with us to make this make a video called
t-shirt war which was like eventually
that became like one of our biggest
viral videos at the time or whatever
around the same time stop-motion 10 or
so so it's so we were we were doing I
guess we were pretty busy I mean we were
doing yeah it sounds we were scrambling
doing both of those things that at once
but I just I remembered that moment when
it was we had shot that all day and then
we come back and we're talking to Jill
on the phone and just asking him to work
with us to make this you know
stop-motion t-shirt war thing and I
don't know that's just the first thing I
thought that that was when you know we
were just we just twist our brains
trying to come up with something that it
reminds me of lot yeah what of what we
consider our Golden Age in that way I
think it's about like just the
possibilities right yeah well and you
know there's a desperation thirsty just
thirsty kids but it's interesting
because and I'm sure you guys have the
same thing but when you have that era
that you kind of look back at well
there's a contingent of fans who look
back at that and just like they always
point to that
and they're like we're like that again
it will never be like well to never be
like that again but I do have this
theory that regardless of where this
goes and what this becomes for any of us
I do think that they'll probably be a
time we may be like I mean links here
well death will be completely white
mine will probably be at least halfway
there I think it stopped I think this is
you have a nice little thing going like
a storm Mystique thing going but I think
there is an appetite for that to do that
again right to be like let's just take a
camera to Alabama and see what happens
and so I do think that it kind of will
come full circle at some point my my
opinion is that whenever you try it it's
never the same it won't be the same and
I tried to like whenever you try to
rebuttal the magic right yeah but I
think that anyone anytime somebody finds
your channel or find something new
that's their golden era right like yeah
yeah back then whatever they fell in
love with exactly yeah now it's
interesting though that's really cool to
hear how long ago was that the story or
eight or nine years yeah and yeah were
you guys already big on YouTube because
you were talking about that wasn't viral
yet oh no it's interesting because that
the video that links talking about
t-shirt war we had a few things that
like got on the homepage back when
getting on the homepage was was it right
it's like feature like even like as
early as oh six oh seven just a couple
of things to Facebook song right but
that was the was a big but that video
the t-shirt war the thing that really
put that on the map was
raywilliamjohnson talking about it wow
so he talked about it on equals three
and ripped us a new one very friendly
way like he was like it's cool but you
know he did his dish stick right well
and he did it because he and Joe were
friends we had never met the guy right
and Joe flew to New York and helped him
with a set up have you ever met Joe no
no you know who I'm talking about
mystery guitar man you don't know that's
he's early YouTube
no okay it's like he was like the
stop-motion guy we're new we're new kids
first he was if he was wave one yeah
right yeah but you know
raywilliamjohnson yeah of course like I
know the name and I know what he used to
do but I never like watched him really
it was before oh man I mean he pioneered
yeah I mean he was everything he did and
he was was like they were they were edit
trick videos where he was the face of
them and he would I don't know exactly
what he's doing now he's doing stand-up
really no way yeah just kind of what I
think he wanted to do other things near
doing weekly video schedule I mean one
of those people that like really proved
that like I'm gonna do this this my
videos come out every week at this time
and then he got he got he started
getting substitute hosts and then he
gave the show over ray now I'm talking
about Joe you don't know they don't know
about somebody why would you tell
somebody about the people they know
about because we don't any way so Ray Oh
Joe a favor and that's why he roasted
our video when you say roast it was well
you know what whatever you call what ray
did to videos okay he'd show the video
and he kind of make fun out did it get
did it rub you guys wrong could you say
roast like oh I was the first person to
publicly call us hipsters and I hadn't
heard the term has that stuck now I know
what I'm going for
right
right but I literally remember I was
like is that an insult I don't it must
be because he's calling his hipster
that's pretty original usage of that
word that long-ago hipster kind of
started one of the moments those those
days it was were the good old days those
are the days of viral videos we don't
really have viral videos anymore do you
notice that yeah like definitely notice
[Laughter]
back in the day because you get 15
million views that don't really happen
even I mean the past 12 months things
have changed so yeah gently with the you
know what getting traction on a video
means you know oh yeah it's uh you got
any theories
[Laughter]
I'm people are sick of hearing me
monologue and conspiracy theory about
YouTube I got theories for days I got
like I've got google analytics like
print out a sharpie do you have to sleep
in that room or did you give them
another I used to be like oh it's a
conspiracy and now I'm fully like I
believe everything she's like Charlie in
the mailroom
always a reference yeah I mean you're a
hundred percent right it's a it's a
different game I mean I think that how
is it affected you guys well you know
it's interesting cuz starting in
November when g-men became one of the
youtubers originals not you know not
like a YouTube read but a YouTube
original they started financing the show
mm-hmm so we don't know how long that
will continue but at least like towards
the end of last year there were two
things that were happening I think there
was a we've always we've always sold a
lot of integrations like branding is
heard a huge part of what we do and that
it became more and more difficult to
sell integrations for some reason like
you
the sponsors themselves were no longer
interested or something else it just
seemed that what whereas you go back to
three years ago everybody was having to
turn down I remember all kinds of
opportunities and then like 18 months 12
to 18 months ago it seemed like that
market kind of changed I don't know if
it was related to people being nervous
about YouTube content or whatever
obviously our stuff has never been
anything that anybody should be scared
of but we supplemented all that with you
know doing buddy system writing a book
doing a tour we started just kind of
branching out so we didn't really feel
it and then at the end of last year when
YouTube started financing the show it's
like well now isn't it we get paid a
flat feet and make the show it doesn't
really matter how I was right obviously
we're doing everything we can to make it
as it's your personal thing you want the
long-term it matters in the short yeah
so it's been interesting I I feel like
because and also with you know we kind
of we just diversified a lot in the past
two years with merchandise and a lot of
other things so it wasn't just relying
on YouTube ad revenue and then just
integrations but that whole business has
changed we've just kind of moved out of
the way or right at the right time
mm-hmm but I don't know I don't know
it's very difficult to figure out what's
going on because they say they they say
all the advertisers are moving from
traditional to digital but okay yeah I
don't know I I feel the same thing
happened to us right when the ad
pocalypse hit we went from making a lot
of money till like barely we're not
gonna within two weeks which was the
scary part like you think you can have
some sort of a plan even though things
are never like for sure we thought well
I was like well no worst case scenario
we'll make this much and then when a hit
we're making like a quarter of what we
thought was worth what it was it was
good cuz it pushed us to diversify like
you guys okay look you just said that
you guys ended up doing a book tour and
mm-hmm
yeah I mean we had seen people doing
that stuff for years you know doing like
fan clubs and
patreon hands and all you guys do
patreon we had one but we closed it
after once our channel got big making
like a living I guess like a comfortable
living that's always been our
perspective yeah I'm interested in in
your in your perspective on that yeah
there are different views about it I per
I personally look my thing with patreon
is that a lot of people call it a scam
okay people go that far like Philly D
for example a lot of people say he's
scamming people with this patreon I
think that's ridiculous
you can't patrons like the most
transparent thing ever like people
everybody knows what they're getting
themselves into right you just you're
giving people money that's the thing
personally I when I would if I had
sponsors and all ton of views and of
comfortable living that I was already
providing all everything I needed for
myself and my employees I wouldn't have
open a patreon I mean it's a it's a
little disingenuous I would say this
maybe yeah I think that's how we've seen
it in the past is that this is the thing
that if you if you can't figure out
another way to do it but I think that
the conversation we've been having
lately is well you could do something
like that
if the people who were paying into that
we're getting something special that no
one else could get think that's so and
not in a perk sort of way but in a
patreon is just a lane for a certain
certain news service it is it is a
subscription service for certain it that
you would begin I think so for people
separate it's not it's not to then to
take the place or to - to bolster what
I'm doing over here where I'm already
making a good living yeah because if
you're like because the whole concept at
the beginning was like if you give us
this much money we'll be able to make
this many videos well once your your
videos are being financed by somebody
else you can't justify that Thanks so I
know it's more like the roosterteeth
model subscription model and doing that
for years it's like you get you know you
go to the roosterteeth the channel and
you'll be like this
lot of content some of it really pops
and a lot of it doesn't but it's like
the the the people who are fans are so
come hard or committed from what I would
say is if someone and like your guys's
position for example wanted to make a
patreon I would say make your own
platform service we had this discussion
would fill it here on the podcast
because he gets a lot of criticism yeah
that's an example and I think we both
were saying that I think like using
patreon has the context that comes with
it yeah I understand that and I feel
like maybe the you think would be people
creating their own platform to give a
tree on kind of gets a new connotation
well right now we could probably do a
thing where it was patreon but it was
white labeled so that it was your
website or whatever yeah and so the
mechanics behind the scenes were the
same thing good stuff yeah that'd be
awesome
you know you guys out there my blank
tree on I think I think if people have
something to offer and people are
willing to pay for it then there's just
it's a beautiful transaction where
everybody's whole and pure right there's
nothing to complain and then you and
then you never know what's gonna happen
I mean duck up completely right because
I mean things have we had a great year
last year did new things that worked we
do a lot of new things that don't work
the GMM is still an ongoing experience
experiment you know the expansion we're
well aware of that so you never know
like this time next year what are we
gonna be saying how big is our team
gonna be who knows so it's just like a
portfolio you know you wanna you don't
want to have it all in one place I think
the biggest issue like either was saying
was just the the context of it like you
you it's something that's marketed as
and how a lot of people use it like I
have I get a hundred thousand views per
video and I have a hundred thousand
subscribers and maybe I get a thousand
dollars a month from from Adsense but I
want to do this full-time and you guys
want me to do full-time so you're gonna
pay me that's the context of it so when
you try to use it a different way I
think that you can get criticized
by people because you've seen artists
taking handouts so it's important to
brand it and in the appropriate way I
was saying yeah but that being said
let's diversify this portfolio yeah cut
it to the me undies and our other
sponsors so we'll be right back after
this brief break thank you and God bless
thank you too for hims for sponsoring
this episode of a street podcast I'm
just gonna put this bluntly does your
dick work does your D wish your dick
worked better
well sexual performance issues are more
common than you think
over 25% of new IDI cases are guys under
the age of 40 what a shame what's EB
erectile dysfunction yellow it's when
your dick don't work well let me tell
you 40% of men aged 40 struggle from not
being able to get and maintain an
erection even the world's greatest
actors can't fake one I guess you can't
fake it as a guy because there is a
climax for guys that is lacking and
females can't fake that even the world's
greatest actor why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
get medicine and make it work again God
and created medicine and therefore God
wants you to have an erection I don't
know for hemes calm ass one-stop shop
for hair loss skincar skincare sexual
wellness for men thanks to science you
can take care of your Edie hims is
bringing medical grade solutions
directly to guys in need medical grade
solutions real licensed doctors offering
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand
prescriptions to give your erection take
away the dysfunction from your erection
it's gonna be hard real hard and real
easy to get it not an herbal supplement
subscription solutions backed by science
one edy pill starting with a V just came
off of patent December 11th and this is
a game changer if you catch their drift
I do
bagger they're talking about I don't
know if I'm not supposed to say that but
there's no waiting room there's no
awkward awkwarder visit there's no
lights save hours by going to for hems
dot-com
it's so easy you just answer a couple
questions a doctor will confidentially
review Babu babs your uncle and bang you
got a boner severe Edie isn't just an
issue for ritual guys in bathtubs it
affects men in the 30s and 40s - so guys
hard made easy
say hello to your little friend go-to
for hems comm /h 3 Edie
yes that's H 3 Edie I love that URL
that's for hems comm / H 3 Edie try
hymns for one month today for just $5
will get you started with just 5 bucks
while supplies last
see website for full details this will
cost hundreds of dollars if you went to
a doctor a doctor or pharmacy for hems
comm / h3e deal that's just come on the
world's a better place when dicks stay
hard they get hard easy and they stay
hard fast and furious boy so if you're
in the market for the that I mean hey
it's a problem guys don't take the
medicine to have a good time man life's
too short
thanks for tip for hymns and thank you
to me on DS yes I love me on deuce
because they make these softest freakin
underwear this land has ever had oh my
god
it's so soft and cozy I wear I'm kind of
a both blessed ewis man I got a thick
waist and when I wear normal underwear
it can chase it feels awful but this
don't chase me because it's the softest
material ever made it's made for motel
alright you want to look good in your
underwear and be comfortable right but
that perfect balance is hard to find
don't sacrifice style or comfort because
me undies calm and you can find the best
pair of underwear in the world mandis
will be the most comfortable pair of
underwear you will ever own made from
sustainably force naturally soft fabric
that is three times softer than cotton
feel that and then feel your shirt ela
tell me what your softer easily
[Laughter]
do they not have got will do then have
dogs for guys maybe I like to wear my
thongs backwards so it splits my nuts
right down the middle and I like it to
be soft when I do now me undies for the
fellas Mandie's diamond seemed patch
cradle your jewels and give your stuff
what they've got diamond seamed pouch
cradles for your jewels give you the
support you need without feeling too
tight that's what I was saying
essentially ladies you'll love the soft
eco-friendly fabric so soft and
touchable and you don't have any balls
that get split right down the middle
your loss
100% satisfaction guarantee they
guarantee you will love these undies or
your money back you've got nothing to
lose by trying it you've got a drawer
full of underwear
you start the morning you take one out
you don't care which pair it is well
here's my promise to you try these me
undies pairs you've got no risk because
it's free shipping and money back
guaranteed in them when the morning
comes you're gonna open that drawer and
you're gonna go for it every time this
incidentally is not male underwear what
again man my me undies is clean this is
such a good day right now me and you
sizing Susan Wofford just for our
listeners get 20% off your first pair
and free shipping
that's right manatees are so sure you're
gonna love that where'd you get a
hundred percent gues satisfaction
guarantee
so go to my undies comm slash h3 that's
me undies Dobbs slash age 3 it's a
limited time offer so what are you
waiting for
start wearing the best underwear of your
life it changed my life and it's time to
let me undo change yours me Andes comm
/h 3 right now thank you to me on DS for
sponsoring us and for him so this is
like the whole package man get into Nick
you're gonna be a new man for the show
thank you so much let's get right back
into it shall we
welcome everybody they actually podcasts
live here with rhett and Link I was just
telling the cast as you guys were in the
bathroom it's it's kind of surreal to be
sharing the table with you guys guys I
mean you guys are legends man I mean
when we were doing the
you know your video and we were like on
it when we were in the restroom right
now yes we were talking compliments
behind your back
no no but in the restroom oh yeah she
was I was just thinking how surreal it
is cuz we used to watch you so long ago
and now it's like we're here together
well let me give you a perspective on
you because it's funny because I think
that we don't end up watching a lot of
YouTube now right then we were making a
lot of YouTube yeah but every in and
then when I see things that are working
when I see things that are popular 99
times out of a hundred I'm like hey I
don't know why be I wish it wasn't right
see I don't think it should be I
remember the first is this D or you know
I move past that the first video of
yours that I saw was when I think I saw
the whole debate like it's like I saw
that in like Jeff form at some point
yeah the first time I understood what
you were doing was when you had you had
idubbbz on he like he came over to your
house or whatever Doug noises yeah I
can't remember exactly what I won we
climb oh yeah I watched that it was so I
started it may have been trending I
don't know how I found it it wasn't so
what was the title in them it was seeing
the first time I think yeah so I watched
that it was like 17 minutes long or
something and then the first thing I'm
thinking because the producer we always
evaluate things as a producing the first
thing I'm like wow why they make it so
long
but I've been watching it the whole time
link come in here and I was like this is
incredible I came in there and I was
like first I was like why are you
watching YouTube at work no we don't do
that watching your video and then I was
like I watched it but then a second but
then I started looking and seeing that
it was working like people were watching
I was like this makes me feel good
something that yeah I understand and
something that I appreciate and is
legitimately funny but and also
legitimately innovative like yeah he was
it brought what specifically it broke
the rules it was it was long I did not
deliver on the title and the thumbnail I
was like there's this guy trying to get
into this guy's house and he can't get
in this way and so long and I was I
don't know it's like it's that moment
when you feel now they've got it
we don't have it yeah honestly there
it's like a threat you know doing it as
long as we have it's like you there's
this feeling that like you I mean we're
both well you're about to be 40 I'm 40
LS that all right well you already there
yeah and you know you're always kind of
you're always asking the question is our
best work behind us even though I really
believe this in front of us you know but
to me it wasn't it wasn't it was it
wasn't it wasn't active I'm threatened
what's up I don't understand it can I
explain and makes me discouraged about
just the platform to see certain things
you know I won't name names to see
certain things that get so big and then
you're just like yeah is this really
what this platform is rewarding
right now wow that's really sucks but I
had the complete opposite reaction
that's all you got it's amazing but let
me say that it wasn't it wasn't
I didn't perceive you guys as an active
threat I just I know
perspective I think that I think that
was something that happened emotionally
yeah because because the fears that you
have of maintaining relevance and making
a living and you know being able to
continue to do something you know use
doing something creative and then you
see something really good what I think
the bigger thing was no one say that in
my doubt the thing I loved about it was
a it was very funny and B it broke all
the rules meaning C and maybe I'll get
to a D it made me feel like you're
making exactly what you wanted to make
you're not you know it starts to eat
away at us when we feel like we're
playing a game or like trying to win a
win a game that of YouTube you know it's
like that it's a it's a rat race it's
like playing a game where the rules are
actually changing so when somebody wins
by learning something that there's no
way you could have been playing the game
that's what it felt like as a viewer
that so then I was left with wow they
must just be legitimately expressing
themselves so it wasn't right maybe a
deep feeling better the surface thing
was like jealousy that like oh no man I
would I wish we could just do exactly
what was on our brains right now but we
got to run it through all these filters
and we got to talk about the thumbnails
and then I I I guarantee you that
conversation devolved into a bitter
discussion over the amount of time that
we would spend on titling and thumbnail
we always complain about that you know
it's like okay it's you you you work
hard to make this movie and then the
only thing that really matters is that
you know the DVD cover art right I hate
it so much it's it is but I'm the one
who makes the thumbnails well for sure
let me just say if it makes you feeling
better I think a lot of our fans
watching it right now are saying
themselves yeah that was the last good
video they made
my deep yeah thank you
I think that that video was kind of a
was a just a beautiful moment where
things lined up for us and and and we
had a great collaboration with items so
it was super funny but I'll say that one
of my favorite formats of videos we've
made and it's hard to find good people
to make it with is this format where
somebody comes for some reason like we
made one with steve-o I know if you guys
saw it it work I thought that one worked
really well would you guys want to make
a video like that where you barge into
my house to react to something and then
we go on some absurd journey together
I would love that's that's the template
I would love to do that link is given me
[Music]
only can do things between the window of
seven and nine I hate saying no and I
think in this in the New Year I think
that's I'm not going to use the R word
but resolution but this I mean this has
been the year so far of trying to
recapture our own ability to be creative
outside of a timeline and a structure
and a schedule and it makes it really
hard to say yes to anything else so
that's why I got this look on my face
it's like I hate saying no to things
that you want to do you know that's very
difficult but you don't want to say a
fake yes which I appreciate and I just
said I would love you know what table
didn't expect to ever make that video
either I would love to but you know life
is life is tricky shredder are you
destroying ourselves it's just a wall
yes sadly there's no magician there well
I would love to make that video with you
guys yeah if it ever well let's have a
tentative commitment
okay 36 months I'll tell you find at
Evergreen video I'll pitch you guys an
idea and then you can think about it
okay yeah do it I need just one
afternoon you just get the ball roll or
evening you know to toss the ball to the
fence that's that's how you get it going
but you guys all have families so is the
weekend city is it really sacred be
sacred
yeah it's gotta be so sacred how many
kids you guys have that's good two and
three Wow
bisect amis not anymore yeah
speaking of ice ectomy video love that
one oh yeah that's blew my mind I was
like cuz to me you guys were talking
about like how is he doing this that was
kind of one of those videos right where
you guys broke the rules you made a
video where you both went and got physec
Tamizh together and it's your videos are
so family friend showed the [ __ ] face
showed the loo are you yeah to connect
your scrotum to your penis
I mean it's funny funny if you posted
that today I think would be demonetized
that's actually that's probably but
maybe age-restricted even because of
that shot no just a whole pretty well do
you think a lot of dick talk listen
let's talk conspiracy theory let's talk
please you know now you're mine [ __ ] I
think to me I think that the driving
force Fair pooped and he's eating it he
has this awful habit you can really go
there's some animals that double
digesting he's not one of those that's a
cow he is once he has once maybe an
antelope
he has once ate his [ __ ] and then puked
it out and it was a puke [ __ ]
awful things have ever seen Oh Treader I
love you but you really you eat your own
[ __ ] yeah man he was just licking my
face as I gonna go oh this guy catching
a whiff here did we cut this part of
Italy or do we let it ride how can you
be so cute and so disgusting at once
like Windex ain't gonna help out with
that loose braid and spray it on you
can't see what they're currently
spraying Windex
yeah he's such a sweet dog Lee if you'll
notice even has not moved from this seat
to try to help in any way at all look I
got it someone's got a man this ship
that's right that's what I say yeah we'd
be okay yeah I mean just give us the
topic okay so they've got under control
yeah it's already past that you know
yeah either you're doing a great job
Ethan is trying to give positive
reinforcement to cover up the his
insecurity with not helping in any way I
wish I could give my boy how do you
discern how do you make a dog not eat it
[ __ ] that is my dog my dog is never
gonna [ __ ] it's yeah I know your keys
apparently are curious they're in the
scat is that some people grow it off
grow out some grow out of it I've read
online and that makes me concerned I
don't like salsa the sub don't cuz I
have a feeling he likes it a lot like he
likes eating [ __ ] a lot and that makes
me already you know what maybe you just
let him do it
about that it's not good for him well
any brain and he brings it inside he
goes on the couch he carries [ __ ] like
oh I'm so happy I've got my new favorite
jute we need pusat does he does he
insist on going outside to puke it
because that seems like a good closed
he's cleaning up no no no he poops
outside and then he brings it inside
that strange and then pubes it's a gift
on one of his blankets oh it was so
disgusting I chose it outside and he's
just trying to offer you guys a gift it
could be a formative period in your
relationship we gotta just take a nibble
of this very well
just accept his graciousness okay so
back to the conspiracy theory yeah so I
know that was you that was your
diversion and not have to go back I'm
not even gonna say conspiracy because
I'm gonna let you fuel the conspiracy
I'm just gonna I'm gonna give you the
perspective so one of the things that we
talked about is it seems like most of
the trends are the things that end up
popping on YouTube right now it's driven
by shredders alright I think this is
your first child you've got like your
new parents yes we're running around God
you've gotta set boundaries guys you've
really got I how do you is apply a
little him wrapped around my dog's
finger trust me I think as I know links
dog can't do anything I understand
that's what I when I first got him I was
like we're not gonna feed him human food
we're gonna put him in his cage we're
gonna do this right
good just one dog good for everyone yeah
he doesn't even eat his food anymore
he's waiting for us to feed him he isn't
eating today cuz he's waiting for us to
give him like food steak Oh see it's too
late look God you've got it you gotta
hit the reset button now yeah what do i
do or just get a second dose right on
the taint that's what it's like for
restart as in getting your dog know add
a second dog how does that help and you
won't care about either one as much
because you won't be able to you don't
have that much love I mean I'm just you
divide it up how much your kid then you
care less you know that's that feels
better
yeah yeah people have more kids love
each child less I mean yes I have this
love to give with actual humans I mean
you should you shouldn't feel bad at all
doing it with with a dog somehow I feel
like because he's so cute and innocent
and blameless it's harder with him even
though down the kid so who knows
great babies they have a comment I don't
know blameless they're always cute I
just watched him eat his own
feces but you know his intentions were
good but as Rhett said you probably just
wanted to hear you should never tell
what am i doing telling somebody else
how to parent you know I mean it's like
the rule number one I'm sorry all right
let's all hit the thing that's driving
popularity and views on YouTube right
now are the tastes and habits of
children thank you for acknowledging
that because that's something that most
people don't understand because you said
for example like when I see something
popular I don't understand why and my
answer which has held true throughout
the time I'd always say is kids it's
kids right and now we have to be careful
how we talk about this because a lot of
people just assume because good mythical
morning is generally family-friendly we
we approach and cross some lines but
it's pg-13 at worst a lot of people just
relate whether your shows for kids well
if you look at the analytics on GMM the
number one demo is 18 to 24 the number
two demo is 25 to 34 and the number
three demo is the 13 to 17 is the is
that is a younger crowd we do have a lot
of kids who watch just because of the
nature of this show so because people go
well did you you guys are making a kid
show or not we're making a show that's
accessible to kids but it's not for kids
that might be completely attention any
posts Malone for example watching every
day god bless his soul right I knew he
was a fan but when he started calling
out specific things from episode so he
really is a family yeah he's told me he
watched you guys everyone I know I
turned to him when he was on the show in
between things and I was like man it is
really nice to have somebody on the show
that's cool know that I mean like that's
it feels good yeah someone like him he's
a he's a cool right so let's reach that
but you see you have these things that
are working and you're like it is the
taste of kids it's what it's what they
want is it you know it's you know it's
my van
nine year old and he is a nine year old
cousin back in North Carolina and like I
saw the stuff that they were bringing up
on YouTube when kind of left to their
own devices but I went back around
Christmas what was it you don't want to
say I can I take a guess I think we all
know was it Logan Paul no I wouldn't I
wouldn't let my kids watch the Paul's it
wasn't the Paul's was it the gums it was
something that it was something it was
some risk um no you know it was
something that was in for nine-year-old
it was totally family friendly but it
was like lots of like very lots of
yelling and I'm saying things in a way
that so kids will listen to me and doing
things that kids enjoy and you know okay
interesting she and I don't have doing
some things that we do on our show but
if you add them in a way that is
obviously packaged for very small
children just pay attention kids and I
don't have anything against that kind of
content but what I have a problem with
is when that kind of content is driving
all the the dynamics of the platform
that I'm trying to make a living on and
for you guys if you're doing something
that is you know it's not it's not as
broadly accessible I mean obviously
there are kids who watch but it's just
like it's more adult-oriented than the
stuff that we do yeah it's stuff that is
more likely to be demonetized under
certain rules it's just like I just
don't understand what the I don't know
what the solution is but I think the
problem is is that everything is so much
of what's being is being driven by these
tastes of what kids want and so
therefore you just get things that
become unwatchable to adults and well
devil's advocate for a second but isn't
YouTube doesn't everybody have the power
to upload a video of course doesn't and
doesn't everybody have the power to find
an audience
no to monetize then yeah no you don't
have the same power as somebody who
doesn't have their videos I would say
back in the
day that was true there was a pure
democratic process of like the best
rises to the top but in today's world
YouTube back-end is controlled by
machines and classifiers and algorithms
that the people are working YouTube
probably don't even understand how they
work right they give them information
and then they they're it's machine
learning right so they watch a million
videos and then they show they have all
these really complicated algorithms they
show videos to average users and this
one dick got less clicks and this one
got less watch time and it's just this
huge insane fathomable no human could
understand it
huge working machine and there's just
way more kids on YouTube then there are
adults and they sit there and they'll
watch the same video over and over again
yeah a lot of videos will get kids with
the way they listen to music is they'll
put one song on and they'll listen to it
for 40 times in a row right yeah
children do yeah
adults don't do that normal adults don't
do that well-adjusted adult so you're
saying is that a shot at me cuz I don't
do that no and so I'm saying that I have
observed children watching YouTube
videos and they watch they get into by
the way we do not recommend don't watch
kids watch YouTube it's like a whole
layer so they'll click on the video you
know watch the same thing over and over
in theory that there's people re
watching videos and it's fudging the
numbers well I think definitely that's
part of it host you get they should that
really blows my mind is like these toys
channel reviews and we talked about how
there's no viral videos anymore these
have like a hundred million freaking
views really views is a huge but I
remember the way we thought about you
know we had these we were talked about
the other day we had this Baby Einstein
was this thing that was I he's probably
still right it was a DVD see I mean I
had VHS copies that were given to us
when Lily was a baby she's 14 now yeah
so we would we would put the kids down
in front of this it was but it was just
it was just this DVD where kids would be
playing with stuff and you know it was
footage of hands playing with hands
playing with toys classical music and
because it was called baby Ines
maybe was making our kids smarter series
okay this should trips me up how does
YouTube or the DVD people who ever how
do they decide that this person with
hands or this person playing with
spider-man else however is better like
what subtle weird [ __ ] that I don't
understand me are these like masterminds
like evil geniuses who play with the
Barbie doll the right way they end up
getting 100 million views then there's
well ten thousand I don't know how to do
the same thing I don't know not figured
it out to begin with but I do know that
they took the same principle and listen
I would take a DVD and we'd be on a
vacation I might have just brought one
right well my kids would watch it five
times in a row and I feel it horrible as
a parent for having to let my kids watch
that much screen time at that time but
sometimes when you have kids that's just
the only way you can escape and
sometimes they eat their own feces right
principle that's operating the same
operating in those hundred that's where
those hundred million views are coming
from yeah and I think it's in one sense
it's a good thing but if it's shaping
everything else and it's influencing
everything else and those I don't have
any announcers I don't know what the
answer it's like all goes to one pool
yeah the problem that I see on YouTube
now that really grinds my gears as they
say is the Paul brothers the kids stuff
doesn't bother me because here's how I
see it there's all these eight seven six
five year olds who are consuming so much
content and they're gonna grow up
someday and they're gonna be coming
looking for our videos the kids today
the twelve and that's true of the
teenagers too but they're the idols the
people that these people look up to the
Paul Brothers but that's kids too that's
young kids it is a driving I would say
it's like between eight and fifteen okay
yeah these are like really awful people
as we've learned it in the case of the
Paul Rose and before it became public
knowledge where we all were like oh yeah
these guys are low character people they
were being promoted by YouTube they had
they had movies they're being
recommended they were in my opinion as
far as I can tell a very conscious
effort was made to promote them because
they knew that their appeal was so
strong and and undeniable so I really do
fear about like youth being corrupted in
a way well there's no filter like on
television executives I I agree with one
part of that so and when I say kids I'm
I guess I am including like 8 to 12 8 13
8 to 14 because I am thinking about not
not just the toy videos but I am talking
about because those are different there
they are those are like - that's like
that's just yeah but but but so though
in the way that a toddler will watch a
toy video with very little discretion a
twelve-year-old will watch the Paul
Brothers with no ability to see they
don't know what's beyond yeah what work
what character is right and so and be
able to see somebody who's just me me me
me this is what I own this is who I am
this is my world this is this is my
pasta you want to be a part of this kids
haven't developed the a lot of kids
haven't developed the moral compass yet
to make decisions about this is probably
not the kind of person that I want to
spend a lot of time buying their stuff
and watching their content and so but
but your theory is that they've been you
know manually push no doubt I mean just
look at Logan and Jake Paul were like a
bit centerpiece of YouTube rewind
channels like us I mean well I'm there's
huge channels that have been in the past
three years huge channels you guys know
like filthy Frank for example idubbbz
channels like these have dominated the
prior years in terms of growth and views
they're not invited and meanwhile locum
take Paul are front and center they're
being offered shows and you know when
you give someone a movie or show through
you to read generally they come with a
certain amount of promotion I personally
have a conspiracy theory that there is
some backroom chats about who to promote
and sometimes it's great sometimes it's
not when vine collapse all these whiners
came over and they all the Sun just
dominate
the whole platform Jake and Logan Paul
providers there's people like Liza Koshu
who I think is super talented I love her
sure she has deserved success but her
growth was in my opinion on organic yeah
hers and all of her contemporaries and
well we're huge fans of hers as well
huge fan and I think I put her in the
category of someone that first of all
met her and she's like a quality person
yeah I have to agree and also her
content is like you get it you see it in
your like this is like a special talent
this is a person that's got special so
good Tahlia and it's not something that
just twelve girls are into it's
something that I can watch and be super
entertained by when it gets to theories
about why something pops and why
something doesn't pop it's just it's
like took me it's like looking into just
an abyss well we can speak for the the
growth of good mythical morning when it
really started the subscribers started
to really gain exponentially a few years
back we went to YouTube headquarters in
order and we and we made the rounds in
in music departments but after what
after your huge explosion this in the
middle not in the middle in the middle
of so this was what four years ago this
is like 12 25 2015 okay there the
question the point of us going up there
was to collectively figure out how it
was happening interesting yeah I mean it
was when you guys started exploiting was
it just kind of like you were doing your
thing you're doing thing all then all of
a sudden you're just like yeah well they
I mean the algorithm was tweaked and it
was trying we were talking to algorithm
people like I was I was joking with them
who's gonna show me the algorithm I want
to go into the room where the
rhythm sits you know and they were kind
of laughing but then they're like well
we can't you know we a couple of people
thought I wasn't joking and they gave me
the serious answer which was but we did
we can't show you we did you know but
because there is no they did we went
into the room with the engineers and
then we went in there here's the
algorithm and he turned his laptop
around it was all this code and then he
turned it back around but my point is I
mean in all those meetings that we had
with with the technical algorithm people
as well as I don't I mean we met with so
many people when I made the rounds that
day in San Bruno but it was trying to
figure out what contributed to the
success story you know they were they
were analyzing and and and trying to
read the tea leaves of their own
algorithm to figure it out so it started
there certainly wasn't one team that we
met with that was like yeah we did it
yeah because I I mean they're very you
know don't get me wrong I'm not here to
toe the line for anybody but that's
honestly the impression I got when we
went up there it was like hey check out
they did a presentation check out this
amazing success of good mythical morning
in terms of watch time like a night you
know and then and then they were trying
that we're trying to figure it out in
the room I find that interesting that
you guys were looking outward and said
being like hey our shows are great and
of course was it that simple so for me
the analogy I like to think of is it's
like a it's like an ecosystem right and
you've got an ecosystem is constantly
trying to reach equilibrium just you
know you've got an island that's got
different animals and those animals
represent different channels right and
it's being but you've got humans who
come in and they tinker with the
ecosystem because they have the power to
do that and they make these little
changes and they don't realize that oh
well if all of a sudden we you know kill
some of these rats then all of a sudden
there'll be less cats or kin
that's the fitting is fitting in this
analogy about YouTube but so I think
that sometimes people are there
tinkering with things so to play the
devil's advocate and try to be a little
sympathetic to that side of it to the
YouTube side of it it's like I think
ultimately what they want is they want a
healthy platform that's got that's
rewarding people who are doing who are
doing great content that's going to make
them a lot of money you know is going to
please advertisers since now advertisers
have suddenly said we demand to be to be
associated with content that isn't gonna
compromise our brand which I understand
and respect that I to there but
sometimes I think that you've got a lot
of people working on this thing and
pressing a certain button that's a movie
tree and then all of a sudden it's like
whoa there's this imbalance and now this
thing is happening now we're a little
bit embarrassed and now we have to come
out and do some PR things so I can't
imagine how difficult it is to manage it
one thing I'll say for sure there's a
ton of different teams there and they
all don't really communicate with each
other because it's such a big company so
what you're saying is definitely true I
think when the one around the time you
guys blow up was around the time that a
lot of channels blow up it was kind of
like a new wave I think like PewDiePie
jacksepticeye and markiplier were all
blowing up as well that the watch the
switch the watch time was that one was
around that time yeah and I and I think
they were looking for shows like you
guys you guys were in the right place
right time you're making great content
and and it's what they wanted I did
gently right we've always said that was
right place right time yeah we've always
but when you say they were looking for
shows I I think I think what what what
we understood was that nobody looked at
our show and made any decision because
then they said oh is that what we want
people to stay on the platform so we're
gonna reward this is what we were told
it made sense we're gonna the algorithm
has been adjusted to reward people
stayin on the platform videos that keep
you watching youtube videos not even the
same channel on the platform so the you
know you don't abandon the video you you
you watch you retain
through the video if they're longer and
you're retaining them even better so if
it's a let's play or if it's two guys
behind a desk algorithm don't care as
long as oh wow this is 12 minutes 20
minutes well in another in another and
another because the first thing that
blew up with the watch time algorithm
was gaming channels and then natures and
then so all the Let's Plays got here you
know what I think they tweaked it and it
tweets in time it was a game it wasn't
gaming channels
it was leafyishere I think
single-handedly killed I don't want more
by the way when you guys were coming I
don't think they ever made any any
choices and I think like the growth of
channels like leave he's here as proof
of that because it was all about watch
time is king have you know about him
yeah so he's like he he was it was
either guy who basically invented the
lets playing and doing commentary at the
same time kinda didn't ban it but he
popularized it okay he would just talk
over footage of video games yeah but he
was a real nasty guy yeah he would make
fun of kids and people with autism and
like he was just a real nasty guy right
and he was blowing up he was getting
like I remember he was posting every day
yeah he's posting every day but I
remember one month he was getting like
like over him to three million
subscribers in a month or so or not that
much but it was insane right he was he
was the fastest growing channel at
YouTube for like six months and everyone
was just like man this guy is [ __ ]
awful yeah he's a really trashy dude I
feel like they directly reacted to that
yeah let's play is inherently aren't a
like existential threat in my opinion
yeah well and if you you know and
basically well I remember thinking that
it I cut you off clear well everything
that we've ever been told is that it is
it is it is the algorithm and that is
the soul you know force behind this
thing and it is difficult as that is to
believe you it seems like if you've got
if that is the case then if you've got
one person who's sort of
screwing that up for all let's plays
then they've got to make a change to the
algorithm but then everyone gets swept
up in that I'm just supposed to just
targeting that one person yeah so it
does kind of make sense when you see
certain genres suddenly and maybe you
know if all of a sudden this the
apocalypse thing is rewarding the safest
most you know kid-friendly content it
makes sense that you know a kid unboxing
toys is gonna get a hundred million
views good it's not that simple
obviously but it does seem like now
though to go back to your original point
that there is kind of a there's a very
doom and gloom right now I feel like on
YouTube and in the sense of what people
are watching to and I don't know I it's
I get frustrated with YouTube because
they they actively ignore content that's
geared towards adults they don't promote
it they don't give and I can't say like
they exclude it from the algorithm I
wouldn't say anything that dramatic but
they certainly don't give them YouTube
red shows or movies or any of the other
service that they give to other people
like Logan and Jake Paul for example and
for us or you guys but you're I don't
know if it's uh I don't know if it's an
age thing or a family-friendly thing but
either way they're just there's such
like [ __ ] I don't know just annoying
it's like it used to be the Wild West
sees what do you want are you offering
you got connected I don't I don't I want
to see more adult content I agree well
what do you think of I remember the the
very beginning of the Apocalypse and and
I guess it was I remember the video was
it was offensive for some like it was
like a it was racist or something I
liked the member you mean the PewDiePie
video no not that but the very first
light when like some brand was Isis
which let's be honest pretty bad place
Brad so I see video so this is this is
this obviously this is not something
that any brand wants but it seems like
the reaction to that was to suddenly
d monetize a whole host of videos that I
mean their advertisers have been
associated with non family-friendly
content since the beginning of
advertising course so I just I that
never computed for me it was like okay I
was upset with the advertiser so I was
like okay listen yes there was an
anomaly somebody your your your your
commercials came before a video that's
awful and that doesn't associated with
that exact and it's nobody's like
watching the Isis recruitment video and
being like oh my god coke it's not
something that happens all the time it's
obviously was a mistake
it's an obviously YouTube you know but
we're in a super reactionary time right
now where if you don't take a stand for
that kind of thing and it's like if one
brand says well we're out of here
because of this anomaly and then the
next brand doesn't say we're out of here
as well think something's wrong with
them that's the word that's well that's
way things fortunately even did when a
lot of companies were boycotting other
companies continued spending and there
was a lot of media articles like shaming
the company's suspend and it's like well
which is I mean it's just it makes
absolutely no sense I'll tell you this a
couple months ago during the shooting in
um in Las Vegas that awful tragedy
seeing I was watching CNN live I put on
TV I wanted updates and they're rolling
to five minute commercial breaks while
it's happening
exactly so will you tell me what what
are the those brands that are buying
member olih but yes they attack people
on YouTube you can't talk about those
things on YouTube if you talk about
those things you get D monetize it
who the brands are having a crisis of
conscience I don't understand what
they're thinking if they're if you're
willing to run ads on any news channel
any any news channel at all tragedy
awful things Ulta a lot of people say
that it's a it's a you know an actual
effort to either advertisers to get
price reductions or
traditional media trying to deal
legitimacy to I don't know there's a lot
of does that hold that whole deal I mean
that that that hurt the movement towards
you know I think the thing that YouTube
hasn't seen yet is it hasn't seen that
sort of culture defining product right
in a way that like you know Netflix or
Amazon some of these other they've
created these properties that everyone
is talking about in a positive way in
adults or talking about them at a
positive way adults are only talking
about the negative things that they
finally realized their kids have been
watching I mean that's the way it's yeah
that's way it's exploded yeah and so I
just think if you're if you're desperate
to create those things that really
define the cultural conversation around
entertainment it's yeah you got I I wish
I could say I just wish they would have
taken a stand against some of the brands
but they you can't because I the brands
are holding holding the money well a lot
of people said well what are they gonna
do not come back it's where all the
views are yeah I would have loved to see
that but their advertising company let
me ask you guys this you said you
wouldn't let your kids watch the polls
what do you guys think about the Paul
brothers how are you I only ever watched
one video so that does make it more
difficult for me to answer mm-hmm you
know cuz I knew I mean we knew we met
Logan we met Logan at something years
ago I was like it's a fun this is he he
was from vine right yes and I think
that's that's when we met him in New
York at some event and then we exchanged
numbers somehow and then you know I was
exchanging texts with him years ago when
it was hey I got this movie move
I'm working on I want you guys to be in
it some movie that hasn't happened
mm-hmm it may not happen I guess I
certainly haven't talked to him since
any of this yeah I mean I think I think
my impression again never met Jake my
impression was up until this last having
not really watched any of the content
except just kind of went something went
wrong I think my impression was that
Logan's cool you know I think I would
always say I would be like look that
it's not my kind of thing I'm not into
it but like I met him one time he seemed
like a cool guy I mean it was definitely
like a little too high energy for my
personal taste but then I was like but
then I was like but Jake I mean Jake's
got some issues you know but
unfortunately I had to say I just feel
like that look is kind of falling into
the same path it's you know there's
there's a lot of vloggers there's a
first of all there's just a lot of
people in general in fact most people
are all about this it's all about me
it's all about my world it's all about
my Empire it's just some of us are
better at hiding it than others but I
think the thing that's that's scary for
me is when we get to a place where
people can own it without any shame at
all can make everything about them and
their perspective it's almost a selling
point and then and then no one is there
to call them out on it right who's like
they can develop just hordes and hordes
of fans who just say hold on is it I
don't think it's cool that everything
that this dude says is about getting the
attention back on to himself yeah that
that's the one video I watched over your
shoulder the well it was it wasn't if
after his return he's only seen the
comeback video I've only seemed to come
back no no after that when he was in
today it was an announcement video we
was just giving an update on he was
standing next to the pool talking about
okay
okay yeah every greatness was back he
was he was standing of
in front of his pool with the guy with
with his entourage jumping in and out of
the pool and hitting each other you know
espousing his greatness and I was
shocked I mean you keep waiting for the
punchline honestly I was keep waiting
for the punchline and then you're like
no this is it serious
I I heard him best described as he's
like the embodiment of somebody that you
think is awesome when you're like 12
you're like that's the coolest guy ever
who I want to be yeah if you're if
you're a certain 12 year old I mean I
have I have one of those and I don't
think he would say that I know my 14
year old says that she never have
anything to do with watching any of
their videos and that's not based on any
conversations we've had I just asked her
what her opinion was probably middle
schools maybe high schools is a little
bit outside the range but it's like it's
the Pollard's first the low game and
they all wear merch like little gang
wars it's pretty nuts five from what
I've heard well better you know
interesting Lee so if you think about
hip-hop yeah it's very analogous to them
so you go back to the early days of
hip-hop and hip-hop as it exists today
and it's just like this bravado and just
bragging about who you are and what you
have in but let's not say all of but but
there's there is a that is a part that
there is a large slip the bling culture
yeah the bling so because I got a 13
year old and and we try to be pretty
liberal about the things that he can
enjoy and he can make his own choices
more than I more choices than I had and
so he's pretty much allowed to listen to
any music that he wants to and so but
the thing is as I tell him this is like
I want you to be able to tell the
difference between Kendrick Lamar and
low pump you know I'm saying I want you
there yeah because because one is like
super thoughtful and thinking about
where is this cultural conversation
going Kendrick and then you got a little
pump which I can't even name a song but
it's just like it's like
for the is for the club or first listen
to that he can't hear ya dad I listened
a little pump when I want to get pumped
up before a basketball game and I listen
to Kendrick Lamar when I want to think
about something and I was like just as
long as you have the ability to decipher
that yeah but but because there is that
but I think that what the Paul brothers
are doing right now is it's just
completely clouding that because in
hip-hop you can be like if you if you
were to sit down with some of these
hip-hop artists who are all about me me
me and their content and you just had a
conversation with them you probably be
like that's just my act yeah sure but
but I think that the vlogging is
blurring the line between well acting
was the person and I think that yeah the
vlog becomes the person big time I was
written you know if you even go back six
months ago or even a year ago even
further and watch Logan's vlogs
he's like a normal guy yeah like I said
I remember a few years ago meeting him
and just thinking like this guy's high a
little high energy he from for me but
yeah I'm like you seem like a genuine
dude who was just trying to make it yeah
like that that video guys mentioned we
were goofing on Logan Paul and at the
time I mean Gila we were like he's not
that bad you know maybe he doesn't
deserve it like we really thought like
you know he he exaggerated it maybe it's
not that bad
we gave him like we thought about naive
and making the video cuz we don't felt a
little bad making fun of him for that
fast forward today and he's stomping
around his 8 million dollar mansion
tasting dead rats yeah way to me this
may be you know I don't know that that
has any indication on well I mean this
may be to me obviously the suicide
forest video was crossing so many lives
it was just the dumbest thing out that
was the sum of how disconnected but it
was it was just a symptom yeah it was
just a symptom and it's just like you
you can its the videos where he's
stomping around the around the house and
bragging about who he is and what he has
now you should join the gang that are
ultimately more problematic in my mind
but that is like all these videos now
that's what yeah because if you isolate
the incident the suicide forest it's way
worse because it's it take you know
taking advantage of this person
disrespecting that's coming too I stand
there but it's it but it is it is a sort
of a peek symptom of a bigger underlying
problem that and that's why when
everybody gets so upset about the one
thing and they're like he did this is so
bad you two better make a stand you two
better just kick him off let's sign up
let's do a petition petitions people
want to do petitions all the time to get
people kicked out of I don't want they
got kicked off of a pledge the platform
I want people to develop the wherewithal
to make a decision to not watch it we
can't we just expect our kids are
growing up in a culture right now where
because that would that would take care
of we we want the organizations and
charge to make all the decisions for us
we want you Twitter to know we want you
YouTube to ban this person what can we
just go quip the kids with a mind that
makes a decision to just filter
themselves you know I'm saying but
that's the parents responsibility
responsibility but like I said would
that would lock it's like as opposed to
saying you can't listen to this and
listen I'm not trying to say I'm a good
parent I'm doing my best but my
intention in doing this whole thing of
letting him be exposed to things and
then but learning how to decipher is in
an effort so that he develops in mind
that when he leaves the house it's like
he can make his own decisions about
stuff he doesn't need to block somebody
on Twitter because they offend him sure
you know what I'm saying yeah absolutely
or expect Twitter to ban somebody
because they offend him yeah I mean you
know I was there's a part of me that's
I'm concerned for him as a as a human
you know that is you know he's made he's
22 he's made these horrible decisions
they're both very young and now he's
he's he's just doubling down on just his
self aggrandizement you know it's like
he's doubling down that's true he and it
is that is that a trap you know is he
falling into a trap that he's set for
himself you know and and bringing all of
these people that he's influencing along
with him so I mean before him we learned
the lesson to not judge a person just
based on the content they
because it wasn't you know we we we made
the mistake of judging people just based
on oh what the the content they make in
my opinion is obnoxious and then you
would meet the person in real life
wow this is actually this is a human
mm-hmm and this and okay they're playing
a character that's working you know it's
they're they're they're gaining traction
you know they and at a certain point
it's like you can't help yourself here
you know at a certain point it goes too
far
he certainly gone too far yeah and so
that's that's the difference here I
still feel for the guy
yeah that you know it's like can
somebody just intervene on an
interpersonal level you know I know
someone who ran into him a week ago and
just not on camera not in any profession
just like on the street I was like man
if that was me well what I've said or I
just told you I have his I have his
number it may not be his number anymore
should I text the guy you think that I
would like to talk just reach out on a
human level on a human level I don't
know yeah cuz that's the thing I don't
want to see the downfall of Logan or
Jake that's I just what I would love to
see is just an acknowledgement that this
is not a healthy way to see yourself or
the world you know what I mean
sure and also because it cuz because
there's just so many kids who are just
so captivated by right now and you can't
and you also can't behind behind well my
contests not for kids I mean parents
should be making the parents should be
the ones if you're if you're doing
content like he's doing you're going to
attract that audience and it would that
becomes a you know great responsibility
so I don't know I I still I think in the
end hopefully I mean first of all the
the crazy meteoric success that they're
enjoying right now and nobody ever that
never lasts
yeah right I mean eventually sure yeah
and so maybe before that ends where they
still got a platform though
okay the suicide forest thing seemed
like the perfect event to bring about
that kind of self-realization honestly
thought I was gonna see a meaningful
change from that and he came back
what I saw was someone trying to make a
point that they weren't gonna change
because everybody wanted them to like he
was pandering to his audience and coming
back like bigger and crazier that's what
I saw
right yeah that's what yeah in the one
video I saw he was bragging about the
petition and then he said I'm gonna sign
the petition right you know and I you
know it's if you're it's it could be a
coping mechanism for what's what he's
the pain what do you having all those
people actually hate you just and yeah
and it's you know and unfortunately the
coping mechanism of doubling down on it
it's gonna work it's working yeah you
know it's making it worse for him and
everybody else eventually right it's an
interesting thing and to their credit
this is something we've never seen
before
the popularity of those two guys and
what they've done and like they've
revolutionized like merch
oh it's Rafi honest we are thinking
about merch differently since we've seen
what they're doing and every youtuber is
we are it's a team
I've heard rumors these are just rumors
I don't know but that Logan makes 10
million dollars a month selling merch
could be possible every every every
middle schooler apparently is rockin
maverick merch as far as I know yeah I
mean but yeah the way that he's built a
brand that's that's bigger than himself
yeah all that yeah there are things to
be commended and there are things that
can can that we can all learn from but
it's just the when there's not a
separation between that character and
the real person that's the problem that
dad's that's what and and and to give
the guy full credit if I was 22 years
old and had that level of success I
don't know that I would have been any
better off oh that's uh that's uh you
got lucky with who we hired we also got
lucky with the fact that we were
basically 30
right with kids we were you know I mean
not not that old but when all this
happened and it was like you know man
when I was 22 years old as a teenager
Fame as a teenager that would have been
what was that done at 22 I wasn't doing
anything I was playing video games I was
worthless to this planet at 22 I had no
value as a human being I can you really
I'm not being hard on myself we we
didn't find success on YouTube till her
late 20s also right yeah I think that
makes a big difference so yeah I mean
you have to be that forgiving but it's
it's can I show you something just to
kind of segue out of this topic and just
lighten the mood a little bit okay
it may actually do the opposite I hope
it doesn't what do you think about this
I wanted to show them to by that merge
song by Jake Paul it's just so fun and I
think you got as musicians as a you know
triple threats as a song over the year I
think that you guys will appreciate it
is a new song no he made it around
Christmas time yeah it's a Christmas
okay my gonna look at where am I gonna
point my face to look at this what's
gonna be on the TV screen yeah it was a
Jake Paul all I want for Christmas so
him and and his brother went on this
just completely brutal competition two
summers because they have the same fans
and December's as you know the biggest
time of the year to sell stuff and so
they both just went balls they both made
like 10 songs but they're all they're
all elaborate poised to sell merch and
so it came to a head when Jake Paul made
this song though it's just to this day I
think it's on the sound board dan can
you grace us I actively decide on a
daily basis not to watch this type of
style yeah and you're you listen this is
your my house now you don't have to say
anything I just want you to enjoy it
because I know you're not gonna watch
this
you're gonna go home he doesn't really
go tell your mom she's got to buy this
song you guys got to watch more we never
do that
even is shameless as we are about
getting people to buy our there's this
built-in governor that there's there's a
certain amount of shame the shame meter
starts going up right but maybe we're
just not being honest with ourselves
maybe Logan and Jake just just represent
perfect honesty at this point and we
should just be making songs about how
you should buy our emergency if we
really want you to buy our merch alter
the filter is gone that is interesting
there it and maybe this is the maybe
this is a future ethic maybe this is
just so I know how you looking a
person's got merged well you know how
would you look back I we feel the same
way about our merge and why we choose
not to say it because we're you don't
want to proclaim it to the world well
just be embarrassed this is the future
Bharat make less money than be so
embarrassed but knowing you know but
what Rhett saying is that boy if I if I
if I threw that cost awareness yeah the
shelter the self-awareness out the
what people wouldn't if you write a song
like this thank you you think your fans
would respond well I mean they would by
that much they well they they would know
that it was a joke
like at this point but what if it wasn't
if it wasn't a joke you think about the
type of communities that we so I on our
community for a little bit the mythical
beast it's like I think that we have
built a very quality community like we
did a thing today that's gonna go up in
March where we're getting people to sign
up for something that's potentially
could save people's lives I want to get
into the details because I want to wait
for the episode but like we got done
with the episode I was like hey I think
that was a great use of the platform and
like it makes me feel as good about
anything we've ever done and B I really
think we're gonna get a lot of people to
do this because I think we have a an
amazing fan base and so I think that
we've a decade of the kind of content
that we've created as and then you get
into this loop where you start creating
content for the audience you know and
it's just like I'm doing things trying
to anticipate what they're gonna like
and I think if you've got a good
community you ain't that makes your
content better ultimately and so I think
we've gotten to this place where we
can't get away with that because they
wouldn't let us get away
I like the keeping you I'll say we
wouldn't let ourselves get away with it
but at this point I like to think that
we build a community that would that
keeps us in line well I'll say to you
guys credit
there's not many channels on YouTube
that can build to the size do you guys
have without participating in drama or
mudslinging or anything beyond just pure
entertainment which is what you guys do
and I think which is why you guys are so
beloved by us and everybody in YouTube
to is because you guys are just
honest-to-god entertainers and you don't
[ __ ] with any of the peripheral stuff on
YouTube that like and we're I mean our
biggest explosions came from drama from
one where they're just frankly speaking
right yeah they come for that you guys
did it the hard way the honest way with
you but then you get us a talk some
drama than today but yeah nothing that
we said
have been said before exactly I bring
good honest people in here and I squeeze
them for the bats
no but seriously like and and I think
that's kind of more the problem again
feeds back into what we were talking
about earlier to kind of just wrap this
up this whole conversation up you can't
really get big on you to anymore without
giving in to the dark side huh
do you agree with that I don't know I
guess we'll see I'm waiting to see like
besides this like vloggers invasion
that's the big thing right what's the
next thing I think this year's gonna
tell us a lot
yeah I'm looking forward to seeing what
what's next yeah I I have hope me too
I mean yeah if you you know go back to
life that you talked about her yeah you
know I think she's she's she's pure and
good yeah and you know what I regret
that I said that her growth is organic
because I don't want to take away the
credit she deserves for being great even
though I may think that but I don't want
I she deserves the success she has Yeah
right and I don't think she would have
got to where she wears shoes
less talented anyway let's let's let's
fight let's do a hard right turn here
let's get off this now give me that
chorus one more time though just you
okay but that's really all this what all
I want for Christmas is that Jake Palmer
my the favorite line that I love it's
gonna be it's gonna [ __ ] your whole
night you gotta buy at all
good talking about you merged before we
got you
what's going on here Murch man I'm
telling you
merch is worth flip it's at my dudes
this is some lip balm can't rival do you
arrive on my lip balm you guys have some
weird stuff no no don't ask
yeah yeah I do you mind that up friends
my closest friends in North Carolina
just started a company and they were
making like soaps and lip balms and
stuff it was working but doing this on
the side and there and we were just home
for Christmas a couple years ago things
like what if you you and Link sold a lip
balm yeah actually I was put I was I was
getting him to put on a beard oil that I
had it cuz he hadn't just grown his
beard he was like I can make this I've
been interested in making this so he
made a beard oil for me a lip balm for
link and then we were just like almost
as a it it wasn't even it wasn't a joke
but it kind of again yeah Murchie but it
was like legit like they did all this
research they may and we like put a lot
of time into the development people sort
of buying it now I got a permit we've
got it call me we have a cologne that is
priced at new audiences over yeah
you sell beard accessories for Christ's
sake right yeah so it's been I don't
know it's been it's a fun experiment to
to try these things and like they're
like legitimate products but yeah what's
the link come on March at we saw your
merch over there you want us to we will
keep all the money
yeah we're just what's that funnel
you guys are somewhat known for eating
and doing gross awful miserable things
on your shelf right
what is the grossest miserable most
regretful thing most suffering you've
endured during that process the most
suffering is that is the hot peppers
without a doubt hmm it is take those
like ma most recently though the one
that we ate for the we were challenged
by benjamin juma babish right did he do
it
he challenged he he ate a hot pepper
some some kind so then we ate a trinidad
scorpion which is actually not as hot as
the carolina reaper we had eaten before
but something happened man if something
broke yeah yeah whenever we eat stuff
we're also thinking of how we can we be
entertaining you know it's like eat the
hot pepper and it's like I'm dying but I
have to make this funny yeah you watch
that video you just give up yeah but
that's almost the most how did you he
had a great what was that I felt pretty
good I was hurting pretty bad but I I
could tell that something bloomed in his
stomach like you know each peppers
different and you don't know what you're
gonna get what's already in there in
your stomach and I knew he would never I
mean so we I mean it was it was life I
mean there's no there's no cutting in
the middle of this thing so wait you
guys did a lot well I mean once we
started we said alright for 10 minutes
we're not going to eat or drink anything
when we had different stipulations for
the Carolina Reaper for 10 minutes we
didn't eat or drink anything we just
said there and took it
that was the that's what we decided that
was how you wanted the show format to be
right so I knew when he went I looked
back there and he was in the fetal
position on the couch
how long in the bed was after the 10
minutes no that was during that 1 minute
you didn't make it and then we went
through good mythical more so that's
another that's another
Damon in the same position I know all
through good mythical more I was just up
there talking and because we were I was
just drooling I was aching well we
turned it into I mean you talk about
self-promotion we turned it into it was
the release of buddy system season to
the trailer we were gonna show that and
good mythical more as we recovered we
didn't know how bad it was gonna and so
you know we thought we'd give more click
'add you know get away at playing that
game I don't know somewhat but it wasn't
nearly as entertaining it's a fact that
every breath yeah yeah people didn't
care as much in you know a second time
around what that was that was the most I
mean so we did it twice we're not doing
it again I mean we were on those we both
vomited it up later we were on the phone
that night at home a couple hours later
and Rhett I was like man I just feel I
mean I was in it well don't some a bad
trip I'll take you through it so you
started to feel better like 15 minutes
after good mythical more was done
shooting you like got up you eating a
bunch of bananas and then you ain't more
bananas that's a good way to kind of
like lie on your stomach if you're gonna
do this type of thing and then you
started to feel better but I went back
into like our dressing room area and I
lay down on the floor and I if I changed
position at all I could I could feel my
the the my stomach contents moved just
enough to expose a different part of my
stomach to the pepper oh wow I just
imagined you know I had a visual image
like I had like a map of the inside of
my stomach and if I if I moved a little
bit I could tell something new was
burning mm-hmm and so guys that they're
eating ice cream trying to be motionless
for the next 20 minutes
and then I finally was able to get up
and I went into our office and you were
said we had a meeting and you were
sitting in there and you were still in a
decent amount of pain I was in a decent
fast forward a couple hours we go home i
text rut and he's like I'm like how do
you feel cuz I feel absolutely horrible
like I could you know I'm it just comes
in waves like your stomach will churn
it'll just turn over and all of a sudden
it's just like like a fires almost out
and somebody Stokes it mmm
and he said I threw up I feel better
mmm I think I gotta do it so I went
upstairs and tried to make myself throw
up did it burn coming out in you can
puke I went back downstairs what's he
doing out there he I thought he might
have been laughing at us is yes it's
through the wall Dan's laughing area but
it's not tied to anything we said so
much funnier than you know isn't that
just like why is he watching something
else we're doing this it took I went
back downstairs gave up and then I was
like I have to do this went back
upstairs if you can't make yourself
throw up but you have to because it's
everything in me knew how bad it was
gonna be yeah it was horrible coming I
mean worse than going because now it's
going through your nose so don't do it
we're not it sounds way worse cuz you
research charity but I saw you guys do
the Ghost Pepper one and he really was
that the one where you're like okay I'm
in my zone I'm fine
that was the Carolina read what's that
that was that real yeah I mean having
the carry on having the air on the
hottest pepper in the world you come up
with things that you're gonna do but
like hitting myself like self
flagellation
that was legitimately hope we make is
yeah
but after the camera was turned off that
time when you guys were like hey we're
all good this is the show and we're fine
was it I was I was at Linc you were fine
I was later he was in the fetal position
on the counter late that night and we
had to shoot another video and it's got
to be hard to be like you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna clock out we does that
mean it's it all runs together to this
point I mean just a whole yeah the OL
nightmare yeah I keep finding new things
though we had lamb tongue this morning
wow people that's the thing like when we
did the spin the bottle gag and by the
way everybody there's videos on GMM good
mythical morning to go please watch when
will you bring support from your
audience but yet yeah Super Troopers ELA
Kleiner's ela kleiner let see we made a
little laugh cuz he calls his fans I'm
like you can't put er there anyway
what's the information pin what up m
nation watch I watch you on our channel
that's the watch yeah yeah watch out the
gross food you got all them grow you got
the gross food but I was thinking like
somebody somewhere cuz it was like pork
liver should or something tongue people
somebody somewhere yes eats that and
enjoys everything but they don't prepare
it the way they don't smear it on a
mannequin face in sex stuff and you
don't know what it is when you go in for
the bite and so yes it works
you could be ground beef and that would
be like a lot of great stuff blindfolded
and it makes everything worse you did
you think it would heighten the sense of
taste in a way they're just copy enjoy
your carpet for us yeah we just don't
correctly I want to ask more about the
hot peppers Oh cuz you guys have done
something that not many people have done
no but my pill
gone that far you said it stings puking
tell me I want all the details bye
I'm curious you puked it burned your
throat you go to the bathroom afterwards
like how long after are you dealing with
the burn well they're talking about
Beaubourg yes I didn't have no exit yeah
but the ghost pepper and the Carolina
Reaper you know I don't know you learn
like how long it takes food to go
through your body it's a real scientific
experiment it's like 12 hours or
something same day no it was the next
day okay you know and we'd learn that
again because we did yeah we were in New
York last year and the hot you know the
hot ones Channel yeah yeah we have a big
fan possibly wasn't in season but we
were so they were like we want you guys
to eat the hottest curry in the world
and we had to do Fallon the next day oh
so I was like I don't want to ruin
because I'm already gonna be nervous
about being on Fallon yeah Artie it
makes me have diarrhea anyway he's like
I don't want something and so and then
we got there and they're whole the whole
point of the game was like first of all
the guy making the curry the hottest
curry in the world had a gas mask on the
guy wears a gas mask when he makes it
that they really should have cut dig cut
to it quiet so you'd have a bite of this
stuff first they were but at first the
creative pitch number one was we were
just gonna sit down and eat the whole
thing and then we were like we get
something wrong we eat a bite of this
stuff that's the only way we can manage
it and I missed two questions out of 10
I think I did take two bites get it take
four yeah a lot of melancholy to two
bites I still had like Oh our wives were
with us that trip and we were we were
out in a restaurant
and in the middle safe let's say five
hours later I don't think it was twelve
it was yeah it was it may be the next
day I don't know we were at a restaurant
and in the middle of just sitting in
this nice meal I was like he was gone I
also had to go then I went to the
bathroom when I came back rat was still
gone and then like all right the waiter
takes away that the plates that we had
eaten off of and we're like ordering
dessert I rest on up and then finally
like the dessert shows up I just see
Rhett looks like a slow death walk no
just like coming back to the table with
this like pale pale face he sits down at
the table and he leans over to me and
he's like you're not gonna have a good
night didn't I read it correctly yes
it's like putting a roman candle up your
rectum but it's not firing out you know
I mean I the roman candle yes have you
guys ever
this is something I've done when after
preparing a spicy meal and I did it with
like habanero I like how you say that
habanero it's not right why how do you
say habanero I think he had an arrow you
know what though I shouldn't say it that
way cuz I it's like I'm speaking English
I can't have all sudden break into like
a flare anyway whatever my one my point
is there's like so many tangent yeah
grab on here I've once touched my
genitals after preparing a spice
okay has that ever happened to you guys
after an extremely spicy moment and has
that transferred to the sensitive skin
on your penis I've been very careful
about that
as a kid I accidentally did that like
touching a jalapeno or something but no
not not as an adult because thank you
because touching the eyes is bad is oh
yeah you know we've done yeah you just
basically you can't touch you can't
touch how much you enjoy it the problem
that I had was that it's not intuitive
because the eyes is like oh it's an open
hole but the penis skin my friends and
everybody listening at home is much more
sensitive than you think because if you
just have a little schmutz on your hand
you get yourself an itch or or dare I
say something more intimate and worse
than that um you are gonna feel it God's
wrath he's gonna say no I don't touch
yourself there thank you
and then that's communicable that is
right I don't know how many people
looking how many times well guys we're
closing on two hours here are we this
has been over two hours you guys are the
I'm I'm still we have a lot question you
guys do write down with questions yeah
we prep did you see Mike I prepped no
well we actually more like in case that
you there's no conversation they're back
so question yeah about those but you
guys are such a joy those are the best
episode but there is one thing that we
ask all of our guests at the end of the
show
some people have something to share some
don't don't feel bad either way we
always ask our guests do you have and
this is I don't feel so stupid asking it
all the time cuz it's like so out of
character but I'm gonna ask you anyway
cuz our fans would kill smile do you
have any ghost stories UFO experiences
or paranormal experiences I just a
preface I don't have any yeah we do have
one I know you guys well the most famous
one
is uh we brought a ghost hunter on to
the show and he used you know how they
can use the radio to him yeah the ghost
like to talk to the right no we yeah a
small aside we want ghost hunting
when post yeah with post in my can Alex
right yeah yeah yeah there was some
friction they made a video that they
they prank they pranked Mike they
pranked Alex I can't remember who got
pranked but basically like Alex like
scratched himself then he went into the
tunnel and then he acts it's a 10 feet
all episode and then he acts like he he
got scratched and he shows it the first
time I watched it like the very like for
two seconds I bought it but why do we
have the ghost hunter on GMM well yeah
did the ghost come after did the ghost
come before no there goes the ghost
appeared that day so we had him on I
thought what's the route was there an
incident well I don't maybe we don't
remember why do we did have an incident
where the light would go off
occasionally and then we brought him on
to the show to tell us what was
happening and he went he did his radio
thing and he was like you know the radio
thing yeah they they brought it yeah we
went well well and specifically what
they do so they have the thing that like
scans for frequencies but then they
haven't just a legitimate radio and you
you run through the stations of an FM
radio like a real station yeah yeah and
the pieces I mean this is BS obviously
but different things from just words and
so there was he's talked on one stations
like NAR to and then he goes to the next
one it's like 40 so he was Bodie we were
laude you know him puffins yeah Naruto
so he was like that's the name of the
ghost and so nartu fody and it's like
haunted GMM for a few years now so
that's the ghost story yeah you
you guys have any very deep cut hip-hop
rap goes when you light flickers or
something a little strange
yeah the you poor little beast will
point it out like they can say in
certain videos but I think the guy I
think the guy who came on our show he a
sexual encounter where that ghost did he
why he was raped by go wide now that's
it go sorry I'd like that's why he said
it was raped by it go that's what he
said I wasn't there
did he give me the story I blocked it
out III pounced on that one and he was
tight-lipped he would not he would not
get details
he's a survivor I think he's sent stars
he says about ghost stories in general
yeah he and here's like I'm not gonna
give these guys the rape story making
fun of his worldview you are you guys
but generally speaking are you guys
aren't believers no but I
I remain open because I actually like to
open like to keep an open mind in
situations like that because I end up
having more fun like if I was going on a
ghost hunt I wouldn't be the skeptic I
was such an [ __ ] that's why you're
not invited they go every week for me
it's different for me it's I I'm not a
I'm not a ghost believer mm-hmm
in mentally mm-hmm but when I have to
take in it's late at night I have to
take my trash out and put it in the
trash can right I run back in the house
that moment you believe yes so I think
that's
that says a lot I mean if I were there I
would have been freaking out right but
in the comfort of my own studio like I
was just like as long as we come up with
an entertaining name for this ghost I'm
happy but I don't want to be caught
alone with NAR - no - for you in your
pants Oh food well bori beautiful can
you say guys thank you so much for I
honestly I love you guys thank you for
taking your time your busy schedule back
please doors open please well that's it
that's all we got
that's the show guys thank you for
watching good morning go to good
mythical morning go to good mythical
more go to mythical dot store know some
of those domains opened up recently I
like that that's a good mythical dot
store tell me tell him we sent you it's
been a long day
I feel like today we had a day like you
guys have every day finished a video
post it and immediately prep for this
you guys have that every day I'm so
exhausted
I don't know and you've got families
[Laughter]
guys god bless you thanks for watching
we will see you next Friday with Shane
Dawson we'll be here so please do it for
that until then have a great weekend and
[Music]
be good
bye guys thanks for watching bye
[Music]